special guests in here the coyotes are
here ladies and gentlemen
sir it was good hey first of all uh
shout out to y'all because when i was at
well i'm still at real 923 but yes sir
previous circumstances when i was at
real 923 y'all came up and did your
thing yeah uh let everybody know what
y'all got going on how they can find you
on on social media all that matters you
can find us at uh coyote for hire on
everything all platforms youtube
instagram all that we're not on twitter
though but yeah we will be but yeah we
got a few eps about to drop one with
cypress one with the label and then one
on our own just on some other [ __ ] okay
i know you guys have been putting out
like a bunch of dope like like content
just rapping like yeah you know what i'm
saying just doing your thing stay active
do what the [ __ ] we do so that's why we
gotta give you all the invite man so
let's let's just let y'all get right to
it man
get that [ __ ]
all right yeah
okay
i'll get this first
there's a blizzard outside
yeah yeah cargo van full of contraband
parked on my driveway loading up an
automatic listening in the shade middle
of a drug deal i thought i need a spa
day with two bad [ __ ] pulling up on a
friday fed's knocking out on speaking no
english [ __ ] bopping [ __ ] on speaking
no english yeah you're cute but no swag
that's a deal breaker i'll probably
leave you in the cold with no
windbreakers [ __ ] i'm faded off the
yickety yak who let these lames in my
section please riddle me that huh all my
exes want the chemistry back but [ __ ]
love where the money imma flip me a pack
i'm coming live from the 310 is mr call
me what you want but can't say broke at
the end if this my shot this a free
throw i was at the crib watching fiends
through the people i do what i gotta do
to get it for my people so meet a chico
you try to stop it in the situations
lead though yeah i'm probably posting
where the bisons at oh my god bro i
can't believe you wiping that she got
miles from malay to barcelona i just
make a stack while i sip on a corona
probably blow a sack that'll put me in a
coma the yodies ain't playing you can
fill in the aroma yeah bounce that ass
to make my frown flip uh keep a watch
out for the crown vixx they harassed me
i was chilling with my ruka [ __ ]
blocking stupidity
that's an understatement on the surface
i'll come i'm really so impatient i want
it now need it now [ __ ] up out my way
ain't no skipping work i give a [ __ ] if
it's a holiday it don't matter i drown
out my whole bladder these whole scatter
i hit make they ass fatter some people
never change and ricky blanc was one of
them
all right hey
they're both playing all right there you
go there we go there we go that's about
time turn that beat up did this [ __ ]
long time coming yo these coyotes for
hire if you don't know about it look it
up that was ricky blanco i'm ready look
guapo watch yo [ __ ] not me check me out
yo
yo yeah
yeah yeah yeah i've been about my
business why you think they call me grop
i took that trap money and invested in
some stock when i rap i raise eyebrows
you would think i was the right always
smoking presidential like i'm hanging
with barack man i'm grinding till the
[ __ ] sunrise i don't sleep look
at my face i got raccoon eyes i'm
running 25-8 i pull up my valet take the
driver 100 that's on a bad day look
latino finno my primo got
[Music]
jacob watch around my wrist is worth the
half a kilo gonna be walking you know
these [ __ ] talking i [ __ ] them and
their toes are curling up like stephen
hawking my yoda hear a shooter flipping
birds like he from boston well you know
we from l.a rapped until i'm in the
coffin uh when you talk about my city
better mention us yo these we just
coming up attitude like hit em up by
tupac we the mexican virgin the
boondocks cortez tube socks trying to
[ __ ] some food eyes hey where they at
hit me on my celly your [ __ ] on top
poochie rubbing on my belly i told her
not to shower like my girl's a little
sweaty cuban [ __ ] i might take a trip
and stay like my kaveli huh the [ __ ]
that good stuff for like a backwood yo
cap [ __ ] i ain't even trying i ain't
that good can't nobody [ __ ] with me i'm
saying this [ __ ] publicly besides jay-z
ain't nobody else above me and i mean
that with the most disrespect waffle bar
we the coldest out the west i heard your
[ __ ] is mediocre at best i'm not done
hold up yeah yeah please don't come at
me with that bro [ __ ] i'm only doing
dope [ __ ] if you cross me i'ma baptize
you i'm on my pope [ __ ] that chilling in
my boat [ __ ] swimming with a dope [ __ ]
she got that water she pull out my rocks
so i'mma go fish skinny dipping sweaty
quick the cocky like my full fifth henny
sipping get shorty the dick i'm licking
fo lips i ain't stingy with the dick
that [ __ ] community my starting father
like the lakers they got matching
jewelry i'm with all the buffoonery you
catch ain't as cool as me we fighting
imma whip your ass you better off just
shooting me
call me all to smoke you like a hookah
if you see me and you shook me it's like
there's 42 of me i'm one man but behind
the mic i feel like hercules i got a
sense of urgency these other rappers
irking me need another perk of me that
[ __ ] is probably lurking me stocking
they be lurking me that [ __ ] is
probably jerking me leave me around your
[ __ ] i'll steal it like a burglary she
was on my bed [ __ ]
hold up hold up
what the [ __ ]
yo yo
leave me around your [ __ ] and i'm
stealing like a burglary i'm the reason
why your baby looking burgundy she was
on her period i still cut it like a
surgery and squat [ __ ] damn the last
four bars were hit
damn hold up do i got more [ __ ] i got
more yeah yeah yo [ __ ] it yeah it's like
god came and spoke to me handed me a
rosary and then it burned in flames and
he told me that i'm supposed to be the
modern day jesus but i had to decline
cause i don't think the world is ready
for the pain in my mind see the way i
see the future is dark i lost hope
although i have one of the biggest of
hearts my heart's broke is what i'm
seeing on a daily basis still fighting
with each other cause we different races
he can't save us although i hate to say
it and i hope that i'm wrong the world
is full of kings and queens but we
acting like pawns how we supposed to
change we don't know how to change
systematically enslavers with invisible
chains i'm like a star in the daylight
dying to shine but the only time that
you can see me is in the darkest of
times even then with the pollution i get
lost in the smog just another lost saw
inside the planet of god somebody saved
me it's like the world is finally crazy
make me think twice forever having a
baby just maybe i'll give birth to the
one that changed humanity from the evil
and darkest ways is guava coyote [ __ ]
yeah yeah and the last ones were a
fumble liar but hey we got it all saying
you got the [ __ ] point hey hopefully
i was on beat cuz i couldn't hear my
voice was a little bit too loud but you
know i mean you get the point yeah you
already are man coyote for higher go
faster a couple of feet
dropping yeah man we got a few things
coming up got a lot of [ __ ] coming up
man
yeah
that was fire good [ __ ] hey hey i'd like
to point out it's 11 in the morning this
guy brought in a bottle of headache
yeah i'm saying real alcoholic [ __ ]
going on this morning drinking coffee in
the morning we drink hennessy